The question isn't about whether dark
matter exists or not.
What's going on is when we measure
gravity in the universe that the
collective gravity of the stars,
the planets,
the moons,
the gas clouds,
the black holes,
the whole galaxies.
When we do this,
85% has no known origin.
So it's not a matter of whether dark
matter exists or not.
It's a measurement period.
Now,
dark matter is not even what we should
be calling it cause that implies that
it's matter.
It implies we know something about it
that we actually don't.
So a more precise labeling for it would
be dark gravity.
Now if I call the dark gravity,
are you going to say,
does dark gravity really exists?
I say,
yeah,
it's 85% of the gravity has no known
origin.
There it is.
Let's figure out what's causing it.
The fact that the word matter got into
that word is forcing people to,
I have another idea.
I bet it's not matter.
It could be something else.
We're overreacting to a label that
overstates are actual insights or
knowledge into what it is we're
describing.
Then I just joke,
we should just call it fred,
fred or Wilma,
something where there is no reference to
what we think it is because in fact we
have no idea.
So here's how you actually measure this
stuff.
Uh,
in a galaxy,
which was the smallest aggregation of
matter where dark matter manifests.
So you look how fast it's rotating and
we know from laws of gravity first laid
down by Johann is Kepler,
and then modify,
then enhanced and given further detail
in deeper understanding by Isaac Newton.
You write down these equations,
say,
Oh,
look how fast it's rotating.
Invoke that rotation rate in the
equation and out the other side says how
much gravity,
how much mass should be they're
attracting you.
And the more mass that's there,
the faster we expect you to be orbiting.
That kind of makes sense.
So when you do this calculation on a
galactic scale,
we get vastly more mass attracting you.
Then we actually can detect,
I'm adding up the stars,
gas clouds,
moons planets,
black holes,
add it all up.
It's a fraction of what we know is
attracting you in this orbit.
And we cannot detect the rest and so we
handed this title dark matter,
understandably I suppose,
but it implies that we know that it's
matter but we don't,
we know we can't detect it in any known
way
and we know it has gravity so it really
should be called dark gravity.
I think the over under on what dark
matter might be today.
I think we're all kind of leaning
towards a family of particles,
subatomic particles that have hardly any
ability to interact with the particles
we have come to know and love quote
ordinary matter and that would make it
matter dark matter as we've all been
describing it
and it's not a weird thing that you
could have a particle that doesn't
interact with our particles within our
own family of particles.
There are examples where the interaction
is very weak or nonexistence you
might've heard of neutrinos.
This is a ghost like particle that
permeates the universe and hardly
interacts with familiar matter at all.
Yet it is part of our family of
particles that we know exist and that we
can detect and interact with.
So if that can,
if we can have an elusive particle
that's part of our own familiar family
of particles,
it's not much of a stretch to think of a
whole other category of particles were.
None of them give a rat's ass about the
rest of us and they just pass right
through us as though we're not even
there.
Now here's what's interesting about dark
matter.
We know it doesn't interact with us
except the gravitational.
And by the way,
what do I mean by interact?
Does it bind and make atoms and
molecules and solid objects?
No,
it does not interact with us in any
important known way,
but it also doesn't interact with
itself.
That's what's interesting.
So if it interacted with itself,
you could imagine finding dark matter
planets,
dark matter galaxies.
Because to interact with yourself is
what allows you to accumulate and have a
concentration of matter in one place
versus another.
These are the atomic bonds and the
molecular bonds that creates solid
objects.
And if particles do not interact with
one another,
they just pass through.
You just have this zone of mass,
not really doing anything interesting.
So dark matter not only doesn't interact
with us,
it doesn't interact with itself and
that's why when we find dark matter
across the universe is very diffusely
spread out.
It's,
it's like over here,
it's not in this one spot and look at
this concentration.
No,
that's not how that works.
An example of this,
you know what is a rock?
It's an,
it's a collection of atoms and molecules
that are stuck together by
electromagnetic forces.
We don't think of them that way.
We just think of them as rocks,
but they are held together by forces on
the atomic and molecular scale and they
bind together and then we get what we
call the solid object called a rock.
If those forces did not work on you as a
particle,
you have no occasion to bind with any
other particle.
You have no occasion.
You have no ambitions of ever becoming a
solid object
to different kind of world.
That would be,
we would not expect that world to have
life as we know it because life requires
and assembly of molecules to turn it
into some separate entity,
distinct from everything else.
That then has fascinating chemical
properties that we call life.